[Music]
i never wanted this for you
i wanted a totally different life
a steady paycheck
kids
a family
[Music]
dad
tell me there's a way out of this
not a quick one
[Music]
we would like you to transfer to another
prison and befriend someone
to elicit a confession
[Music]
we suspect that this man killed 14 women
but we only have one of the bodies
[Music]
larry has vivid dreams
tell me about him in my dreams that kill
women
those are just dreams
in this prison we're the guys
maximum security specializing in the
criminally insane
you want me to check into hell
and befriend the demon
not for all the money in the world
how about freedom
hulk's convictions on appeal
he could win and walk
you have the chance to stop him
don't approach him too early or he'll
know we sent you for him
why are you looking at me like that
like you know me
[Music]
if it gets out there you're here to
snitch
that's going to be a very unfortunate
day
accelerate your timetable
if he walks he'll kill
again and again
[Music]
you think you could be in danger
you are in danger
[Music]
[Music]
you